c'est lors de notre second débat tout de
suite toute cette semaine vous savez on
a décortiqué les enjeux de la rentrée
pour l'exécutif énergie
assurance-chômage planification
écologique on parle de la diplomatie des
manuels macron de la place de la france
dans ce nouvel ordre mondial tout de
suite et donc la stratégie diplomatique
du prêt public pour commencer avec
audrey états
c'est un exemple concret de la stratégie
diplomatique d' emmanuel macron il
assume ouvertement de dialoguer avec
tout le monde même vladimir poutine une
fausse céder à aucune forme de fausse
morale qui nous un puissant très qui a
envie que la turquie soit la seule
puissance du monde qui continue à parler
et être membre de l'otan dois je le
rappeler et a parlé à la russie son
ambition faire de la france une
puissance d'équilibré cette notion de
puissance d'équilibré elle rompt alors
en voie cela cette idée que la france
est une puissance avec qui on peut
dialoguer où il faudrait se tourner vers
la france pour régler les conflits ce
qui n'a pas l'air d'être une franche
réussite en tout cas pour les événements
récents notamment avec l'invasion russe
en ukraine dans l'ordre mondial la
france est considérée comme une
puissance moyenne même si elle a des
atouts non négligeables son armée et son
rayonnement culturel
emmanuel macron ne veux pas qu'elle
devienne le vassal d'une grande
puissance nous sommes indépendants
c'est-à-dire que nous avons des états
unis d'amérique qui sont nos alliés qui
est une grande démocratie avec laquelle
nous partageons des valeurs et des
intérêts communs mais nous ne voulons
pas indépendant ce que j'ai dit et nous
avons la chine qui est un rival
systémique mais avec laquelle il nous
faut continuer d'agir pour trouver des
réponses aux défis communs le climat la
biodiversité pour exister emmanuel
macron souhaite s'appuyer sur une
alliance encore plus large que l'union
européenne qui réunit les pays qui ne
sont pas encore membres et ceux qui ne
souhaitent pas l'être sous une bannière
qui est son idée la communauté politique
européenne l'important que continent
européen affirme ses valeurs propres qui
sont pas forcément exactement les mêmes
que celles des états unis
moi encore fait de la chine où on voit
aussi de la russie dans ce monde de
brutes c'est important que l'europe au
delà de la seule union européenne se
rassemblent pour peser et montrer
politiquement
sa force c'était ce mois ci qu'elle
pourra faire valoir ses intérêts cela
permettrait aussi de développer des
liens avec des pays encore tiraillés
entre l'europe et la russie
la stratégie diplomatique d' emmanuel
macron le nouvel ordre mondial le bras
de fer entre la chine et les états unis
la nouvelle donne européenne provoquée
par la guerre en ukraine beaucoup de
thèmes abordés avec mes invités jarreau
bonsoir bonsoir ancien ambassadeur de
france en israël et aux états unis vous
publiez histoire diplomatique leçon
d'hier pour le monde d'aujourd'hui aux
éditions grasset armée charrier bonsoir
vous êtes éditorialistes internationale
à france 24 spécialiste en géopolitique
stratégie et défense jacques également
pascal boniface bonsoir soient
bienvenues directeur de l'institut des
relations internationales et
stratégiques et vous publiez cet atlas
des relations internationales aux
éditions armand colin
je commence donc par la diplomatie des
mails macron j'avais ce qui s'inscrit
dans une tradition française tradition
de la diplomatie française ou est ce
qu'il cherche à tracer une voie
originale d'abord il est il s'inscrit
dans une tradition française qui veut
que les dirigeants français pensent que
la france doit avoir un rôle particulier
dans le monde qu'elle doit être active
qu'elle doit être présente dans sur la
plupart des dossiers si vous comparez la
france à des puissances finalement
comparables comme l'italie ou même la
grande bretagne vous vous rendez compte
très rapidement que leur leur chef
d'état ou leur président du conseil sont
je dirais beaucoup moins activistes que
le président de la république française
et je ce point de vue là emmanuel macron
s'inscrit dans la lignée de celle de ses
prédécesseurs
oui dans votre livre que c'est le retour
à un monde des grandes puissances etats
unis chine russie japon inde que peu
pesé la diplomatie française a rejoint
un peu si vous avez évoqué dans ce monde
là le magro pas grand chose finalement
quand même un peu et d'abord les
maquereaux fidèle à lui-même et des ans
le en même temps c'est à dire d'un point
de vente d'un premier point de vue il
parle beaucoup du multilatéral mais
ensuite il dit
il faut que la france ait une voix
particulière en particulier vis-à-vis de
la chine puisque ils refusent
l'embrigadement je dirais atlantiste si
josi en dehors d'une sorte d'autant qui
s'étendrait à la chine donc de ce point
de vue là là aussi il y à là derrière je
dirais tout cette tradition gaulliste
voir golo mitterrandiste qu'il reprend
et qu'il reprend à son compte en même
temps de nouveaux vous savez tout le
monde ya à l'époque du général de gaulle
à l'époque de françois mitterrand mais
lorsqu'on regarde la réalité de leur
politique étrangère et que vous savez
ces grands hommes ne sont pas allées de
succès en succès ils n'ont pas changé
l'ordre du monde il y a aussi des
réalités lourde et je vous dirais que
emmanuel macron s'inscrit dans ces
réalités s'inscrit dans le fait que la
france est une puissance moyenne que les
rapports de force joue plutôt en notre
défaveur
l'occident est plutôt en recul sur la
grande place celle du monde et que eux
ils essayent de faire avec ce que nous
avons il essaye de faire de son mieux
armelle charrier emmanuel macron
comptait beaucoup sur la la présidence
tournante européenne pour asseoir une
sorte de leadership en europe évidemment
ça a été balayée par par la guerre en
ukraine cette ambition elle a été
fragmentée en quelque sorte par la
guerre sert que tout son calendrier qui
était prévu à l'occasion de cette
présence tournante il est un peu passée
à la trappe oui alors qu'en plus c'était
vraiment un bon temps pour emmanuel
macron parce que c'était déjà avant la
présidentielle donc de facto y allait
avoir quand même une partie de la
présidence européenne qui allaient être
prises dans la présidentielle française
donc ils avaient quand même concentré
ces axes et il avait un royaume uni qui
s'en était allé une allemagne qui était
plus aussi présente que d'habitude donc
il y avait un rôle français qui pouvait
se faire jouer et en fait il y avait
aussi une volonté quelque part d'avoir
ont parlé à ce moment là beaucoup
d'europe de la défense avoir une europe
de la défense pas tellement défense et
le fait d'avoir une responsabilité
européenne sur les enjeux et c'est vrai
que la guerre en ukraine
a redonné en fait du l'alliance de
l'otan et de leurs données de laura
pardon à cette alliance et donc du coup
quelque part toutes ces questions de
défense elles sont passées effectivement
plutôt sur un milieu plus atlantiste
c'est à dire que lorsque l'on naît
aujourd'hui accaparé par l'otan
forcément du coup on parle moins de la
souveraineté des états alors ça a été un
peu cette cassure en fait qui me s'est
mise en place ces avoirs à la fois
besoin d'europe et en même temps avoir
besoin de ce bouclier américain et ça ça
correspondait pas à l'envi emmanuel
macron qu'il avait parlé de mort
cérébrale de l'otan à un moment donné
pour le revivifier mais qui avait aussi
une volonté a demandé de dire on doit
exister à côté des américains et il
avait en tout cas fait ces déclarations
lors on attendait les actes on voulait
savoir avec quel pays ils allaient
pouvoir le faire parce qu'elle pas
beaucoup de pays européens qui étaient
prêts à suivre derrière donc il fallait
quand même allé taper sur la peau les
épaules d'un certain nombre de personnes
est ce que les grecs allaient suivre est
ce que les italiens les suivent chaque
pays en fait européen un peu une
histoire avec les américains qui fait
que quand on doit parler ensemble il
faut quand même qu'ils arrivent à
trouver ce qui peut avoir vraiment en
commun avec d autres et là ça a été un
peu à mon avis sa frustration pascal
boniface un peu la même question que
pèse la voie des macros en europe
aujourd'hui ma - et moins de 20 ans
depuis la guerre d'ukraine c'est vrai
que c'est le projet français et jeudi à
regret mais je le constate le projet
français d'autonomie stratégie
européenne c'est lui sur les ânes mort
cérébrale c'est pas l'otan parce que
tous les pays européens ont été effrayés
par l'agression russe de l'ukraine et
tous se sont dit il n'ya qu'un seul pays
qui peut nous protéger ce sont les états
unis et si on commence à discuter
d'autonomie strike européenne ça à faire
peur aux américains qui vont se retirer
qui vont nous abandonner donc en fait
les fondements de la politique disons
gaulle au mitterrandisme de que de bons
macron se revendique qui est d'avoir un
dialogue suivi avec moscou pour se
donner des marges de manoeuvre notamment
par rapport aux états unis et de
travailler à cette autonomie tragique
européenne ces deux possibilités sont
pas morts définitivement mais en tous
les cas elles sont très mal paraît elle
ne elles ne sont plus en état d'être
mises en oeuvre pour les années
effectivement dans ce nutriment j'étais
frappé et l'employé quatre ou cinq fois
le terme vassaliser en parlant
effectivement de lettres pas vassaliser
par les états unis
vous parlez de son discours face aux
ambassadeurs semaine dernière par
rapport à la chine mais en même temps et
je rejoins si auparavant la
contradiction c'est qu'il veut à la fois
l'autonomie et la cohésion européenne
mais pour l'instant on ne peut pas avoir
d'autonomie et de cohésion européenne
puisque les européens n'en veulent pas
alors ce bilan diplomatique daniel mach
rond il ça va lui aussi à l'aune vous
l'avez évoqué rapidement de ses
relations avec vladimir poutine sur ce
thème sur quelques autres aussi
lorsqu'il parle de son successeur
françois hollande était critique ce
matin sur france inter emmanuel macron
est à l'image d'une partie de la classe
politique française qui a toujours eu
pour annie brocoli tu parles pas pour la
russie pour vladimir poutine un certain
nombre d'indulgence en réalité ce serait
de notre faute on n'aurait pas
suffisamment dialoguer on l'aurait
violement encerclé on l'aurait même
agressé
d'attitude emmanuel macron ces dernières
semaines et
même un conte a été amenée notamment
dans la période qui a précédé la guerre
a constaté que l'art du mensonge était
pratiquée mais avec un brio exceptionnel
par vladimir poutine gérard où vous
dites dans votre livre que
il n'existe pas de bonne diplomatie sans
l'empathie pour l'interlocuteur et même
l'adversaire donc si je vous comprends
bien mais le maquereau avait raison de
maintenir ce lien avec le dire moi je
pense tout à fait qu'il avait raison de
maintenir le lien et j'ajouterais même
qu'il arrive il a raison de vouloir le
maintenir aujourd'hui deux nouveaux
essais je sais bien que le premier
ministre polonais a dit on ne négocie
pas avec hitler mais moi donc j'ai dit à
mes amis polonais à les y aller jusqu'au
kremlin obtenez que poutine se suicide
dans les ruines du kremlin non on ne
fera pas donc on devra négocier avec la
dmr poutine s'il y a un traité de paix
s'il y a une paix entre l'ukraine et la
russie et ce n'est pas et ce n'est pas
acquis la diplomatie c'est pour parler
au diable et donc je trouve que emmanuel
macron a parfaitement raison à condition
ne pas être naïf et je pense qu'on ne
peut pas l'accuser d'être naïf
parfaitement raison de maintenir le fil
avec vladimir poutine pour le cas
échéant lorsque le moment viendra et on
n'y est pas un
éventuellement nous les fils une
négociation est ce qu'il ya en parallèle
de cette diplomatie des tentatives des
forces spéciales américaines d'éliminer
la nive rpt aux agents syriens ça c'est
du roman policier est en général la
diplomatie vous savez en général la
politique étrangère et le roman policier
ne font pas bon ménage moi je crois pas
tellement au complot et aux
conspirations pour mettre un terme à
cette affaire puis vous savez vous savez
même si on se débarrasse de poutine mais
aussi il ya eu je pense une une trop
grande concentration sur la personne de
poutine mais le sera peut-être pire
parce que les gens autour de lui cc des
nationalismes dur des nationalistes dur
c'est 7 ce qui vient de se passer ce
n'est pas l'acte de folie d'un homme
isolé c'est tout un système politique
qui a mis en oeuvre une politique sur
lequel ils sont globalement d'accord
est-ce qu'il est forcément plus menteur
que les autres joueurs m'ont dit sur la
phase 2 de françois hollande pascal
boniface on parle de vladimir poutine
quand même donald trump aux états unis
qui n'était pas vraiment singularité
boris johnson n'a pas un rapport à la
vérité très développé et il ya quand
même
c'est quand même souffrance aux langues
qu'ils ont tout bon là c'est règlement
de compte personnel entre mais
effectivement c'est bien soit on fait la
guerre jusqu'au bout et on renverse
poutine on le fera pas parce qu'il arme
nucléaire ce quoi il fera bien parlé
avec lui et donc c'est juste une réalité
alors bien sûr il est brutal il est
autoritaire bien sûr il a commis des
crimes de guerre tout ceci est vrai mais
il ya deux solutions soit on gagne la
guerre ne peut pas la faire donc on la
gagnera pas soit on négocie avec lui
alors ce second mandat des macros il
commence avec une réforme de la haute
fonction publique qui tous les
diplomates tam traduit vous pouvez nous
rejoindre pour nous expliquer ce que
prévu à exactement cette réforme pour
les diplomates du quai d'orsay c'est
très familial prévoit tout simplement
d'extinction des corps diplomatiques les
plus prestigieux heures il y a cinq
grades et les deux grades les plus
élevés conseiller des affaires
étrangères et ministre plénipotentiaire
qui permet ensuite d'accéder au poste
d'ambassadeur vont donc disparaître pour
être refondus dans un seul et même corps
celui des administrateurs de l'état
conséquence à partir de 2023 n'importe
quel membre de ce corps qu'ils soient
prêtés inspecteur général des finances
ou issu du corps diplomatique pourra
donc devenir ambassadeur et donc les
hauts fonctionnaires sont en quelque
sorte mutualisé de quoi crier à la
diplomatie en extinction au service
public en danger ce sont les slogans qui
animait la grève du 2 juin dernier au
ministère des affaires étrangères
deuxième grève de l'histoire de cette
institution que craignent au tilt
exactement alors ils s'inquiètent d'une
perte de professionnalisation à terme de
prestige de la diplomatie française
difficile quand on a passé un concours
spécifique avec des compétences
particulières en langues étrangères avec
des compétences particulières matière de
négociation de découvrir combat donc
être finalement mélangé au pot commun
certains craignent aussi à terme une
mutualisation concrète du corps
diplomatique avec eux donc tous les
autres grades et face à la levée de
boucliers emmanuel macro à garder le cap
écoutez
défendre un métier ce que je fais
profondément à ce à quoi je suis attaché
comme vous ne m'a jamais signifié
défendre un corps ce que la réforme de
la haute fonction publique doit
permettre d'enrichir c'est de consolider
précisément les filières d'expertisé les
filières métiers qui sont indispensables
à la réussite de notre action
diplomatique et ensuite il nous faut
pouvoir déployer encore plus largement
ses talents au sein de l'état parce que
nous en avons besoin et mieux agrégé
aussi les compétences techniques venant
d'autres horizons au coeur de notre
diplomatie et vous le savez parfaitement
noter aussi que dans le même discours
emmanuel macron a fait valoir que le
nombre d'emplois au ministère de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères
allait augmenter pour la première fois
depuis 30 ans histoire de mieux faire
passer la pilule puis noter enfin la
crainte de nomination de plus en plus
politique au poste d'ambassadeur en
clair de faire nommer les copains on va
quand même rappeler qu'il n'ya pas eu
besoin de cette réforme pour que des
nomination ne viennent pas du sérail de
jean christophe rufin nommé par nicolas
sarkozy
ambassadeur au sénégal en 2007 à
philippe besson et l'écrivain qui avait
suivi emmanuel macron lors de sa
première campagne nommé consul général à
los angeles par le président de la
république cela avait fait grincer déjà
bien des dents ou alors ça c'est pour la
colonne - on va dire l'école
insuffisamment qu'est ce qu'on trouve
dans la colonne plus quels bénéfices
possibles rit parce qu'il ya aussi
certains qui défendent cette réforme
certains estiment que le quai d'orsay
représente je le cite je les cite une
rente à vie pour certains fonctionnaires
et que ce n'est pas justifié d'autre que
le ministère est trop fermé sur lui-même
en 2019 emmanuel macron avait lui
reprocher aux diplomates français de ne
pas vraiment appliqué sa ligne vis-à-vis
de la russie vous en parliez à l'instant
on écoute emmanuel macron en 2019 et
donc parfois le président de la
république dit des choses se déplacer
les quelque chose puis la tendance
collectif pourrait être de venir il a
dit ça enfin nous on connaît la vérité
on va continuer comme on a toujours fait
je ne saurais recommandé de ne pas
suivre cette voie
d'abord parce que elle et collectivement
inefficace elle nous enlève de la
capacité à faire
et donc dans cette capacité à repenser
les grandes relations il y as entre
relations avec la russie
voilà un reproche qui résonne donc un
peu étrangement aujourd'hui alors que le
contact géopolitique a bien changé on
est passés donc du réchauffement
diplomatique avec la russie au retour de
la guerre sur notre continent ce retour
de la guerre sur notre continent c'est
d'ailleurs l'un des arguments mis en
avant par l'association française des
diplomates de métier cette nouvelle
association qui entend promouvoir la
diplomatie française qui est opposée à
cette réforme qui compte parmi ses
membres d'honneur d'ancien ministre
dominique de villepin le négociateur du
break site michel barnier ou encore
gérard araud votre invité sur ce plateau
est donc la question est facile pourquoi
pensez-vous que cette réforme n'est pas
d'abord est ce qui est intéressant c'est
que finalement c'est le quai d'orsay qui
réagit mais en réalité le président la
république des mets un terme à tous les
corps le corps préfectoral
alors les préfets sont plus obéissants
que les diplomates mais le corps
préfectoral s'est quand même napoléon
ces deux siècles de tradition française
et donc il y à là derrière une vision de
l'état qui est celle d' emmanuel macron
qui est à l'évidence qui n'est pas la
vision traditionnelle de l'état c'est la
start-up nash nation donc voilà on a on
a un tas de gens et on va prendre les
plus compétents voilà et ça va être on
va faire des panels comme dans les
entreprises privées on prendra on
prendra les plus compétents alors
pourquoi les jeunes diplomates
réagissent mais parce que lorsque vous
êtes préfet mahbod si vous êtes nommé
dans un ministère des finances ou
ailleurs aulas bon ca c est à ça peut
paraître acceptables mais lorsque vous
avez fait cinq ans le chinois ou lorsque
votre passion c'est vraiment l'afrique
vous lorsqu'on veut et si on vous
propose d'être sous préfet dans la
creuse et puis c'est une manière aussi
de dire finalement tout votre compétence
eux on s'en moque un petit peu hein
c'est pas ça qui compte vous passerez
par des panels il n'ya pas bon on a pas
besoin d'avoir vraiment des diplomates
mais c'est pas tellement les
ambassadeurs ce que vous savez les
ambassadeurs c'est déjà le président la
réplique peut nommer qui il veut comme
ambassadeur c'est déjà le cas et je peux
vous assurer que certaines ambassades
par exemple rome
ici toujours beaucoup beaucoup
d'ambition les jeux vous noterez
d'ailleurs que là elle n'est toujours
pas pourvus rome à l'heure actuelle je
me demande gare
donc c'est plutôt mais c'est plutôt le
reste des le reste de la fonction
publique vous savez je veux pas être
trop long mais un jour un jeune
diplomate a été nommé à kaboul donc il
est venu me voir me disant qu'est ce que
vous en pensez qu'à bouger dit bon vous
y allez si vous y allez je vous garantis
qu'ensuite vous aurez un beau poste donc
il est allé à kaboul et ensuite pour le
récompenser moi je les mii a gelé mais à
new york et l'inquiétude c'est
qu'évidemment les jeunes diplomates on
les envoie à kaboul ou à bujumbura et
qui est des gens qui arrivent qui se
disent tiens un inspecteur des finances
qui tiens moi j'ai envie d'aller passer
trois ans à washington moi j'ai envie
d'aller passer trois ans à rome voyez
c'est ça devient ce système fait qu'on
ne peut plus gérer une vraiment un
métier qui est différent des autres vous
savez à l'heure actuelle lorsque vous
avez une épouse qui travaille ou un
époux qui travaillent est renvoyée
changer tous les trois ou quatre ans de
poste c'est compliqué vous savez on est
le ministère des divorces un vie les
enfants les enfants qui tous les
trois-quatre ans doivent-elles doivent
changer d'amis donc c'est un ministère
on va pas je vais pas faire pleurer sur
les diplomates à un ferrero rocher je
sais ce qu'il en est mais voilà c'est
c'est en même temps un médium beau
métier mais qui est assez difficile et
cette manière de nous dissoudre dans le
pot commun n'est pas très populaire chez
nous dans la bien compris dans dans ce
discours armée charrier le prêt public a
exhorté nos diplomates à être plus
réactif sur les réseaux sociaux est ce
que est ce que c'est un en creux et trek
en creux en creux c'est est-ce que c'est
pas un corps un peu poussiéreux louis ce
que je veux dire c'est ce que j'ai
entendu dans cette phrase de mâcon mais
ce qu'on peut voir aussi c'est que c'est
l'idée que l'image d'un pays elle se
joue là aussi maintenant et qu'on peut
pas le sous-estimer
c'est sûr que a priori quand on va sur
un réseau social via aussi aussi du
mouvement de contestation qui peuvent
arriver donc ça veut dire qu'on peut
aussi recueillir une parole auquel on
n'aurait pas pensé etc etc alors c'est
vrai certainement que dans la diplomatie
actuelle c'est pas le moyen le plus
simple d'expression et que en plus ça va
vite donc il faut peut-être un moment
donné davantage peser des verbes et donc
choisir ceux d expression mais c'est
peut-être aussi ce que reproche un peu
président macron c'est de dire à un
moment donné il faut que ce soit plus
jeunes il faut que ce soit plus
dynamique c'était un peu la réflexion
qu'il en faisait quand il parlait de la
russie où grosso modo c'était on peut
voir ces choses différemment fait aussi
confiance un président plus jeunes qui
arrivent avec une expérience plus neuf
et donc du coup arrêté puis vision de
menaces la part dont deux interrogés
dans le la phrase macron si vous
cherchez à ne pas appliquer ma politique
faites attention où quoi cet esprit en
mai puis on met en même temps je
rajouterais juste par rapport à ça que
c'est vrai que quand on se demande
souvent où est ce que la france peut
avoir une spécificité par son corps
diplomatique elle l'avait cette
spécificité c'est à dire que on avait la
capacité de connaître des pays de les
connaître depuis fort longtemps parce
que vous faisiez votre carrière souvent
effectivement pas certain nombre
d'endroits et donc que vous ameniez
cette délicatesse et cette précision là
et cette délicatesse et cette précision
là on en aurait bien besoin dans un
confit comment quand on a avec poutine
on aurait bien besoin qu'à un moment
donné plutôt que de dire c'est une brute
qui est en train de s'exprimer on puisse
s'expliquer qu'est ce que c'est que la
vision russe de choses qui sont à
l'intérieur et comme la france elle a
une position particulière en europe on
est justement du côté des américains
mais on est aussi européens parce qu'on
regarde aussi du côté de la russie on
parle pas comme d un pays baltes où on
parle pas comme la pologne et c'est tout
ça en fait qui est aujourd'hui est un
peu balayé et donc c'est pour ça qu'il
faut aussi remettre un peu du coeur à
l'ouvragé dessus alors est-ce qu'il ya
unanimité sur le sur le jugement porté
sur cette réforme louis bélisle
la voix très négativement c'est un
divorce un métier c'est pas quelque
chose qui s'improvisent vont dire que
les diplômes est seront fermés sur
eux-mêmes ça correspond une image
dépassé il ya beaucoup de caricatures et
bien sûr friedman font grève ça bloque
personne mais bon on a quand même besoin
de gens qui sont au contact et moi je me
balade en parlant bassin enfin enfin de
coheed il faut voir que les gens
m'aiment son actif son phase agressivité
civile c'est plus les diplomates qui ne
reçoivent que lors de réceptions un peu
compassé les chefs d'état et les élites
deux pays il ya une diplomatie
économique les gens charge des contrats
et ils vont dans les universités faire
des conférences etc et lorsqu'il avait
en 2019 dénoncer l'état profond qui
s'opposa liban il fallait changer les
gens parce que lorsque j'ai un de gaulle
et mitterrand toujours été suivis par
les diplomates et les diplomates sont
plutôt légitimiste et loyalistes et
légaliste donc c'est vraiment et dire
comme c'était bon il ya toujours eu des
nominations extérieur il faut bien sûr
ouvrir il faut pas que les gens soient
fermés sur eux-mêmes l'exemple qui
étaient cités je suis désolé mais on
peut pas comparer jean proscrit syrte
rifains qui a fait un très bon boulot à
dakar avec bon mitterrand qui nomme son
médecin aux seychelles c'est pas tout à
fait la même chose bon mais ces
nominations il faut un peu de
respiration comme tout corps il faut
qu'il y ait des gens qui viennent de
l'extérieur mais c'est un métier qui ne
se résume pas à cela et on risque bailly
finalement moi je serais pas étonné que
le prochain président revienne sur cette
réforme alors on va parler de ce nouvel
ordre mondial et notamment de ce bras de
fer entre la chine et des états unis
avec en filigrane la question de la
supériorité des valeurs démocratiques
laetitia un relatif consensus en france
pour dire que nos démocraties sont en
faillite ou en péril dans ce nouvel
ordre mondial oui en péril bon c'est
vrai qu'on n'a pas attendu la guerre en
ukraine à vous l'avais dit à tout à
l'heure gérard euros pour voir des
nouvelles puissances émerger la chine
l'inde la turquie la russie on avait
bien compris que l équilibre mondial
était 9,1 après la guerre froide c'était
opposition est ouest et puis triomphe
souvent prosélyte finalement un des
démocraties c'est vrai que on entend de
plus en plus de voix en france qui
constate le péril dans lequel
lord les démocraties sont et d'ailleurs
on part et écouter un extrait de
l'interview de l'ex chef d'état françois
hollande ce matin sur france inter parce
que lui-même le constate si bien
vladimir poutine que 6,6 ping que et que
les personnes qu'ils hantent les
entourent considère que nous sommes des
société décadente déclinante qui sont
appelés à un moment non pas disparaître
mais à se retirer de la scène
internationale en tort il ya une partie
de deux constats qu'ils font en
regardant le fonctionnement de notre
démocratie
divisés
incapables de prendre un moment des
décisions courageuses et ils
revendiquent ces deux dirigeants et pas
seulement ces deux là ils revendiquent
le fait que les régimes autoritaires
sont donc supérieurs au régime de
liberté et aux démocraties que ce sont
les régimes autoritaires qui peuvent
voir loin il est vrai que lorsque le
prix d'un chinois ou président russe on
rencontre un dirigeant occidental il
sait que lui restera encore là pour les
deux ou trois décennies qui suivront
alors que le responsable occidental aura
disparu la démocratie régime idéal c'est
de moins en moins partagée dans ce cas
c'est ce que je croyais les occidentaux
avec les américains c'était un peu à
slogan on va dire dans le monde et puis
finalement c'est vrai que les opinions
publiques elles mêmes témoigne d'un
certain doute parce que rappelez-vous
george bush qui avait désigné comme ça
l'ordre du mal axe du mal finalement les
opinions publiques quand on les
interroge ne sont plus si unanime sur la
nocivité des régimes autoritaires et ça
l'a dit mi-août il a tout à fait compris
hier dans son discours à vladivostok il
a carrément dénigrer l'occident
collective le site 1 qui maintient un
vieil ordre mondial avec des règles
injustes qu'ils ont inventé qu'il viole
régulièrement il a même parlé de la
tentative agressive de l'occident pour
imposer son modèle aux autres pays
évidemment il a posé la russie au centre
de ce nouveau monde tourné vers l'asie
pacifique avec une autre question celle
de des états unis les américains ne sont
plus les gendarmes du monde c'est toute
la question thomas et je rebondissais ce
que vous avez dit vous gerra haut ce
matin chez nos confrères de bfm tv vous
l'avez dit vous-même il n'y a plus de
gendarmes américains dans ce nouvel
ordre mondial
or quand même quand on regarde les
américains continuent de fournir des
armes aux sucres et amiens malgré la
menace a répété de vladimir poutine et
puis quand on regarde aussi le poids de
l'otan sur la scène géopolitique on se
pose cette question est-ce que
définitivement le règne des américains
et le gendarme américain a disparu c'est
à dire que les états unis resteront la
première puissance au monde est pendante
sans doute plusieurs décennies mais je
me trouvais intéressant c'était le
discours de joe biden lors du retrait de
de kaboul donc au mois d'août 2000 2021
où il avait dit désormais nous
n'interviendrons que pour la défense des
intérêts essentiels des états unis c'est
à dire on a une certaine d'ailleurs une
certaine continuité entre obama trump
hebeisen les états unis sont fatigués
ont l'impression d'avoir conduit des
opérations militaires l'irak
l'afghanistan qui ont duré longtemps qui
ont coûté très cher et qui finalement
fondamentalement ont été des échecs ça
c'est la première chose c'est à dire au
fond nous doutons de nous mêmes c'est à
dire les états unis d'où d'eux mêmes
nous nous doutons de nous mêmes parce
que à cause de plus du populisme ambiant
dans toutes les démocraties occidentales
mais en même temps en plus il y à une
modification des rapports de force
d'érable et je le dis les etats-unis
sont la première puissance et le
resteront mais désormais avec
l'émergence de la chine on voit bien que
le rapport de force global a changé il
change aux dépens des occidentaux la
france l'économie française est passé
ainsi derrière l'économie indienne
voiliers et tous ces mouvements vont
vont se poursuivre et c'est naturel
vraiment c'est là c'est un nouvel
équilibre d'une certaine manière nous
sortons des deux siècles de domination
du monde par l'occident que nous savons
que nous considérons comme normal mais
qui finalement ne l'est pas et nous
devons donc essayez de nous accommoder
de 7,2 cette nouvelle réalité
certainement pas en nous accrochant à
notre statut certainement pas faisant
bloc de l'occident on n'est ce pas face
à tout le monde une sorte de bloc
obsidionale mais il faut essayer
d'apprendre sont beaucoup de beaucoup
modestie beaucoup de flexibilité et puis
comprendre ce que les autres et écouter
les autres armen charrier qu'elles
vivent vous vous faites des relations
des massacres on va d'abord par les
états unis est ce qu'il a trouvé la
bonne distance avec les états unis
il ya eu une changement de cap
effectivement entre trump et entre
weiden on a eu effectivement des moments
qui était plus plus tendue est ce
qu'aujourd'hui on a vraiment la bonne
distance il la cherche encore peut-être
il la cherche certainement sur la cette
notion en fait de liberté française que
on voudrait quand même encore incarnée
avec aujourd'hui une alliance qui
devient de plus en plus pesante avec la
guerre en ukraine c'est ça on fait un
peu la difficulté avec les américains
c'est qu'aujourd'hui comme on est dans
une guerre où il ya derrière des
demandes d'armement des demandes
d'intervention etc
quelle est la capacité de faire entendre
parfois des voies différentes or je
pense qu'ils emmanuel part comparé
moment justement quand il va discuter
avec vladimir poutine ou à ces endroits
là ce moment là a des envies aussi
d'avoir une capacité de réflexion propre
à la france mais dans ces cas là il faut
effectivement aussi avoir un budget
conséquent et on va avoir de moins en
moins un budget conséquent sur la
faillite des démocraties monsieur ce on
parle de match le mot est un peu
triviale mais mais cette question des
valeurs démocratiques et blur et de leur
place dans le mot de presque jamais
employé le terme de leur popularité
pascal boniface elles sont effectivement
de plus en plus contestée où ils sont
contestés chez elle la mieux le 6
janvier l'assaut du capitole regarder ce
qui se passe au royaume uni regardez la
faiblesse interne des gourmands français
de la coalition allemande auriez ce qui
se passe en italie les démocraties ne
sont pas en bonne forme et donc elle
doute d'elle-même et on peut bon et puis
ce qui a changé sur tous et je rejoins
ce qu'ils aient gérard hausser que
pendant très longtemps nous démocraties
occidentales forts de nos valeurs dites
universelles on a voulu faire la leçon
au monde entier est ce que le reste du
monde nous dit maintenant c'est écouter
on n'a pas envie de vous écouter on a
nos propres valeurs on a nos propres
intérêts et en tous les cas vous n'êtes
pas toujours aussi vertueux que vous le
prétendez et donc on va défendre nos
intérêts on ne va pas vous suivre un
règlement et c'est ça qui change et et
par rapport à emmanuel macron
effectivement lui un peu pensé parce que
par rapport à l'europe est l'objet de
suivis s'agit ni sur la russie la marge
de manoeuvre qui essaie de garder ses
par rapport à la chine il a beaucoup
insisté dans son discours pour que par
rapport à la demande très forte des
états unis de faire une grande coalition
anti chinois au nom justement de cette
alliance des démocraties contre la kth
des pays autoritaires et met à croire
beaucoup insisté dans son discours pour
dire non ne serions pas vassaliser nous
avons des intérêts spécifiques à l'égard
de la chine et ne faisons pas une sorte
de prophétie auto-réalisatrice en
solidifiant lax entre moscou et pékin
alors justement ce vous l'évoquez je
vous propose d'écouter un extrait de ce
discours des mails macron devant les
ambassadeurs c'était il ya une semaine
sur la diplomatie française et la chine
la géopolitique se structure
progressivement autour d'une compétition
entre les états unis et la chine et
cette compétition elle est problématique
pour nous à plusieurs égards
d'abord parce que l incite la chine et
nous le voyons à l'oeuvre à redéfinir
les règles du jeu internationales en
installant un narratif selon lequel ces
règles aux fonds seraient centrées sur
la puissance américaine etc ce qui était
un consensus universel établi et
maintenant quelque chose qui peuvent
légitimement contestée et en proposant
d'ailleurs on cherche à bâtir des
solutions à valeur mais des navires
mieux à plusieurs géographe normes
internationales qu'ils soient en
concurrence en compétition avec celui de
washington était le garant en dernier
ressort on s'inquiétait aussi le nôtre
tous ces égards
ça fragilise la capacité de l'ordre
international gérard vous expliquer dans
votre livre le diplôme est le diplomate
pardon doit se mettre dans les
chaussures du dirigeant chinois observez
ce qui se passe aux frontières de ce
pays gigantesque ça explique beaucoup de
choses on oublie ça qu'est ce qui se
passe aux frontières de la chine pour
comprendre finalement le latitude ou la
diplomatie chinoise le fondement des de
la diplomatie c'est l'empathie c'est à
dire qu'il faut essayer de rentrer dans
la sphère cognitifs de l'autre dans le
monde de l'autre ce qui veut pas dire
qu'on va qu'on va être d'accord avec lui
mais pour essayer de comprendre ce qu'il
fait et non pas simplement pour dire
celle empire du mal c'est l' axe du mal
voyez si vous regardez la chine si vous
vous mettez à pékin et de pékin vous
regardez vous faites le tour de votre de
votre pays toutes vos frontières plus ou
moins sont déstabilisés ou tenus par des
pays où sont hostiles vous avez
l'afghanistan vous avez l'asie centrale
déstabiliser la frontière avec l'inde
n'est même pas fixé et il est deux pays
sont évidemment des pays qui ont connu
qui ont fait la guerre enfin si la chine
qui a envahi la harpe qui a envahi
lalinde vous avez taiwan vous avez la
péninsule la péninsule coréenne ainsi de
suite et donc d'un point de vue chinois
surtout que les chinois ont le sentiment
de re devenir la première puissance
qu'ils étaient jusqu en 1750 la chine
était la première puissance mondiale il
ne faut pas l'oublier ne l'oublient
certainement pas donc moi si je suis un
géostratège chinois pékin je dis bon les
enfants ça va pas bien il faut donc
améliorer la situation alors par exemple
la mer de chine du sud il viole le droit
international j'en suis d'accord mais
par là arrivent 80% de l'énergie
chinoise alors n'oublions pas qu'en
relations internationales toute mesure
défensive est vue comme offensive par
leur part l'autre côté donc vous pouvez
considérer d'un point de vue chinois que
contrôler la mer de chine du sud c'est
un acte défensif pour protéger l'accès
l'accès de l'énergie cette énergie dont
ils ont utilisé dont ils ont tant besoin
et donc le problème que que nous avons
avec cette nouvelle puissance c'est de
dire attendez mais est ce qu'on peut lui
laisser un peu de mouvement où est ce
qu'on va l'arrêter tout de suite voyez
c'est c'est une relation internationale
on sait que c'est une situation qui est
très dangereuse parce que d'un côté vous
avez une puissance un peu déclinante en
relatif les états unis de l'autre vous
avez la chine qui fait qu'ils jouent des
coudes et donc il ya un moment où
est-ce qu'ils comprendront quelles sont
les lignes rouges de l'un et de l'autre
est ce que les états unis accepteront
l'idée que la chine finalement est une
puissance savez quand vous regardez la
chine il ya 70 bases américaines en asie
et dans le pacifique
quand vous regardez vous avez
l'impression aussi vu de pékin que le
pays est en est est évidemment encerclé
évidemment des états unis n'ont pas du
tout la même la même vision de la
situation donc ça va être dans les
années qui viennent c'est la relation le
président de la république l'a dit c'est
la relation qui va structurer les
affaires étrangères est-ce que ils vont
réussir à trouver une modus vivendi
est-ce qu'il va y avoir des incidents
mon avis il va y en avoir un des
incompréhensions de part et d'autre des
malentendus est-ce qu à sarajevo 1914 la
guerre mondiale je pense pas parce que
ce sont deux puissances nucléaires
n'oublions pas ça dieu merci la
dissuasion nucléaire joue son rôle et
d'ailleurs c'est intéressant parce qu'on
pourrait chercher à comparer les
tensions sino-américaines
avec la guerre froide entre l'urss et
les états unis
bien anthony blinken le chef de la
diplomatie américaine à cette question
il répond non c'est pas la guerre froide
la chine est le seul pays qui à la fois
l'intention de remodeler l'ordre
international est de plus en plus les
moyens de le faire sur les plans
économiques diplomatiques militaires et
technologiques du web oui on l'a nous ne
recherchons pas d'un conflit ou une
nouvelle guerre froide au contraire nous
sommes déterminés à les éviter nous ne
voulons pas empêcher la chine de jouer
son rôle de puissance majeure ou
empêcher la chine ou tout autre pays de
faire croître son économie et de
défendre les intérêts de son peuple
alors ça c'est le discours officiel
diplomatique on est fin mais c'est
intéressant de le rappeler armée le
charrier parce qu'ensuite il ya eu les
faits ces tensions notamment vous
l'évoquez autour de taïwan la visite sur
place de nancy pelosi la présidente
démocrate de la chambre des
représentants
comment vous l'avez analyser cette
visite qu'est ce que ça signifie pour
vous en plus ça arrive en plein pendant
la guerre en ukraine donc justement
quand on voit qu'avec la russie comment
est-ce que ça réagit donc forcément
c'est qu'on va tester on va prendre le
pouls on va voir comment est ce que vont
se comporter les chinois derrière elle
savait forcément qu'elle allait déranger
que derrière il ya d'avoir une réaction
mais c'est aussi le moyen amendes et des
américains de montrer que il ne lâche
pas qu'ils sont quand même présents et
que donc du coup il s'intéresse aussi
pendant ce moment d'été où tout ça s'est
produit où il fallait aussi rappelé
effectivement qu'il n'y avait pas que
l'europe et que la chine redevenait donc
il y avait peut-être aussi de la part
des américains à un moment donné une
capacité de réflexion de se dire que
peut être qu'ils étaient allés dans la
guerre avec la russie il avait un peu
oublié leurs ennemis et que donc du coup
il fallait se reconcentrer sur la chine
en plus acheminé pris dans le vide et
c'est donc ça fait partie des choses qui
sont extrêmement importantes je pense en
visite en sachant qu effectivement
derrière les chinois vont réagir et donc
ils vont réagir à la fois militairement
mais ils vont réagir aussi
économiquement ils vont réagir aussi
diplomatiquement parce que tout ça est
imbriqué aujourd'hui est qu'il ya une
réflexion qui se fait sur les sanctions
américaines qui est aussi poussé way
pascal boniface dans le discours dans
cet extrait du discours dans tim kaine
c'est intéressant on peut se dire là on
est plus sur le au delà de la visite de
nancy pelosi sur la capacité des
américains à accepter de laisser cette
licence chinoise c'est oui mais alors la
question elle est là elle n'accepte pas
ils l'acceptent pas pour l'instant
depuis 1945 qui sont la première
puissance du monde ça veut dire que oui
mais les américains il faudrait dire il
faut laisser un rôle un peu
proportionnelle à la jil sander et son
on est promis on veut pas être déclassé
dans tout l'est dans tous les domaines
en 2001 la chine pèse 10% du pib
américain elle empêche jouissons 10%
c'est angoissant pour les américains et
donc effectivement ils ne peuvent pas en
plus ils pensent qu'ils sont supérieurs
moralement à la chine puis il mérite
cette première place et qui serait tout
à fait injuste que la chine leur prenne
le rôle qui est le leur de tout temps et
de toute éternité pour revenir salle de
la visite d'un psy pelosi on voit bien
la différence gesticulations et
géopolitique parce que byden était
opposé à cela alors tout le monde a
applaudi le geste courageux de madame
pelosi est là elle a rien risquer mais
au moment où blinken essayé de séparer
un petit peu la chine de la russie on a
raffermi les liens entre moscou et pékin
on a effectivement durci le ton de la
chine tout ça pour dire est un triomphe
médiatique mme pelosi qui a été à
l'encontre non seulement de la sécurité
de la région et même des intérêts
nationaux américains et donc très
souvent les postures son imposture et de
l'approuver dernier chapitre il nous
reste un peu moins de dix minutes dans
dans ce dans ce sens public un chapitre
centré sur l'europe gérard araud vous
l'avez on l'a évidemment dit plusieurs
fois on découvre la guerre sur le
territoire européen depuis six mois vous
dit qu'on doit se réhabituer à vivre une
tragédie et non un drame bourgeois ça
m'a surpris cette cette expression vive
et un drame bourgeois oui c'est à dire
lorsqu'il y avait un conflit on oublie
que nous sommes quand même le continent
de la guerre
au xviie siècle il ya eu une seule année
sans guère genre en europe 1669 donc
nous sommes le quand ils nous avons
donné au monde guerre mondiale etc mais
depuis 1945 à part la guerre civile en
yougoslavie nous avons eu l'impression
de nous être débarrassés de la guerre et
nous avions nous avons l'union
européenne qu'elle oublie un mécanisme
de maintien de la paix plaisir lorsqu'il
y a des différentes européen on va dans
les corridors de bruxelles et on règle
ça par les négociations et on arrive
toujours à des compromis il est donc on
pouvait penser que les régler le conflit
entre l'ukraine et la russie par la
négociation c'est à dire on pense que
c'est ça la manière de faire des
relations talent moderne que la guerre
c'est archaïque et donc lorsque poutine
a envahi l'ukraine tout le monde a dit
mais il est fou ce qu'on n'arrivait pas
à imaginer que il y ait une rationalité
de la guerre nous sommes sortis de
l'histoire une certaine manière comme je
dis nous sommes un peu des des
bisounours et et 2 seul coup nous avons
alors en plus nous avons pu le faire
parce que nous étions sous la protection
américaine disons le clairement aussi ça
nous a permis la protection américaine
qui d'abord interdit les les disputes un
peu trop tendu entre les partenaires les
américains ont soutenu la création au
début de l'entreprise européenne et nous
ça nous a permis d'avoir les ne pas voir
ne pas faire d'efforts militaires très
important puisqu'on était protégé par
les américains nos amis allemands en ont
ils les italiens encore encore plus pire
ou mieux on en profiter et bien voilà
c'est fini donc de nouveau les états
unis eau sont ont été rattrapés par les
basques par poutine parce qu'il était en
train de partir sur la pointe des pieds
d'europe moi je connais bien
l'administration baden en gros il aime
beaucoup les européens mis les considère
comme étant la vieille grand mère qu'on
aime beaucoup qui a été un peu violente
et parce que 3 1 pt était était vulgaire
mais voilà on attend rien parce que
c'est en asie qu'il ya non seulement le
risque la chine mais il ya aussi les
potentialités de croissance les
américains résonne aussi dans ces termes
n'est ce pas nous on a une 2% on est
fiers de notre croissance le l'asie
cette assiette oui pour cent donc il y
avait vraiment une volonté de la
puissance américaine et là bon elle est
un peu à les rattraper et donc les
européens nous devons nous adapter à ce
nouveau monde la guerre est possible de
nouveau que va ferrer d'orane tôt ou
tard voyez on le voit bien lui monte le
ton face à la grèce il a déjà plusieurs
reprises menacé les autres les halls la
zone économique
rec est là et les eaux territoriales
chypriotes
qu'est-ce que jusqu'où jusqu'où ira-t-il
voilà c'est un nouveau monde d'
équilibre et je moi je ne pense pas
qu'il faille y ait roth qu'il faille
faire la guerre au contraire il faut
avoir un gros bâton pour pouvoir
négocier donc il faut que les européens
quand même que le travail des niches
sociales c'est d'abord d'empêcher la
guerre surtout c'est tout et je crains
et et voiliers d'une certaine manière ça
peut nous donner une leçon parce que
l'époque de la domination de l'occident
ça a été aussi l'époque où l'occident a
utilisé la force à tort et à travers ça
passe ça a été le l'irak l'afghanistan
échec échec ça a été aussi la france en
syrie et la france au mali et l'on peut
conclure que c'est aussi un échec donc
peut-être qu'au moins seul nouvel
équilibre des puissances conduira les
puissances occidentales dont la france
et peut-être les états unis à se dire
que bon il ya des diplomates il faut
négocier il faut parvenir à des
compromis et que c'est sans doute mieux
que de vouloir utiliser son gros marteau
mais bon comme vous le savez lorsqu'on a
un gros marteau tout problème ressemble
à un clou
puisqu'on parle de l'europe je propose
d'entendre une réaction de du chancelier
allemand olaf scholz y plaide pour un
élargissement de l'union et 7 je
m'engage pour l'élargissement de l'union
européenne aux pays des balkans
occidentaux de l'ukraine de la moldavie
et en perspective de la géorgie une
union européenne de trente ou trente six
états mais qui sera différente de notre
union actuelle je vois lever les yeux au
ciel à vis à vis à bois très bien à 27
alors à 35 à 36 bon l'ukraine c'est un
peuple martyr là encore on confond
émotions et analyse le peuvent les
martyrs on doit l'aider accueillait
réfugiés l'aider militairement mais le
pays n'a pas le niveau économique le
niveau de gestion pour entrer dans
l'union européenne ça déstabiliserait si
on veut que l'union européenne soit en
fait un espace économique impuissant il
faut l'élargir à tous ces pays là s'en
prendre plus de garanties donc non c'est
vraiment enfin de toute façon là elle a
même pris son ticket d'entrée pour
pouvoir entrer
on a réagi dans l'émotion 10 ans est un
signal envoyé à moscou il faut aussi
envoyer un signal ukraine qu on est
solidaire mais c'est confondre de
problème il ya le problème de la gestion
de l'union européenne est ce que c'est
un projet politique l'ukraine
si l'ukraine rentrer dans l'union
européenne sera le 50e état américain
qui sera membre de l'union européenne
armée charrier sur sur cette question de
l'attractivité finalement de l'europe on
a eu le sentiment que cette guerre en
ukraine pouvait renforcer l'attractivité
pour l'europe d'enjeux notamment ces
pays des balkans on apparaître d'ukraine
il ya d'autres pays qui candidatent
est-ce que vous l'analysez comme ça vaut
aussi où est-ce que c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué que ça je pense que oui
forcément il y en avait très activités
de l'union européenne quand on est
européen quand on est ou craignant quand
on a vu à côté par exemple un pays qui
s'appelle la pologne qui était aussi
pauvre que ce soit à l'époque et puis
une fois qu'il est rentré dans l'union
européenne vous savez c'est 20
kilomètres séparent la frontière et puis
d'un seul coup vous avez des hôpitaux
vous avez des écoles vous avez du loisir
vous avez un niveau de vie qui augmente
vous mangez de la viande plus souvent et
vous êtes dans les positions - rural
donc forcément ça ça fait rêver
ensuite forcément il ya aussi des
aiguillons qui était rang qui ont été
envoyés pour aussi de la part des
américains certainement donner une
impulsion importante maintenant la
réalité c'est qu'on est en train de
parler à un moment un peu différent
parce que comme il ya eu la guerre on a
des pays européens qui sont en train
d'exploser par les inflations on a cette
crise économique qui va se mettre en
place et on va voir aussi quelles vont
être les conséquences sur l'europe et ça
peut-être pas tout à fait ressembler à
celle que l'on connaît merci beaucoup
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat je rappelle les titres de vos
livres histoires diplomatique jarreau
leçon d'hier pour le monde d'aujourd'hui
publié aux éditions grasset et puis cet
atlas des relations internationales
pascal boniface atlas publié aux
éditions armand colin
belle soirée à toutes et à tous votre
prochain rendez vous politique tiny sera
encore aux questions de diplomatie et de
l'iran du crime puisque rien de mansigné
reçoit demain matin le général vincent
desportes professeur de stratégie à
sciences po et hec
[Musique]